I've been told that I'll definitely win today's basketball.
[Music]
Isn't that great
?  Even if you carry it for Gill, you still have this much magazine.In a
small room, the knife is often stronger than the
inside.Especially if you have high agility like
a lotus.Equip it horizontally on the back of your waist.  When using it
, pull it out with your right hand and the enemy is bigger than Ren.Cut under your crotch and cut your inner thigh.The
femoral artery runs through it, so you can deal a lot of damage.
If you get an i5, aim for the Achilles tendon sideways through the boot,
the opponent has fallen down.
With a knife that can damage the brain, the neck and here are probably the only places where you can aim for instant death with a single blow
.